please welcome to students at Marjorie
Stoneham Douglas high in parkland
Florida who co-founded the advocacy
group on gun control
never again MSD David hog and Cameron
Caskey
[Applause]
[Music]
are you guys knowing you get tired tired
yeah you're running around the country
doing doing a good job thank you yeah
trying to make our voices heard oh
you're doing that and more I mean you've
you've done a great thing and turning
your grief into something positive and
you have a March let's first just talk
about that in the future and what's
gonna happen with this movement it's on
it's when is it scheduled for Washington
its March 24th okay a March in March on
the 24th and what are the goals well we
are we with the March we want Americans
to stop being afraid of demanding our
politicians to take action they work for
us we don't work for them and the March
is us the March is us coming out and
saying to our employees you guys suck at
your job right with with the March we
want everyone to come out bring their
parents bring their kids everybody in
the nation is either a child or a former
child and that's what we want to do is
say this isn't about red and blue this
is about protecting the kids okay
[Applause]
[Music]
and I also have a boycott right in mind
for and I think that's a great idea yes
what we're trying to do with that is we
essentially we met with some of the
legislators in Tallahassee and we felt
like we didn't really get far enough
because they wouldn't even discuss with
salt weapons there what they did discuss
there was porn as a public health
emergency which just goes to show you
related shooting issues yeah yeah but
sadly that's the only one that these
lawyers seem to care about is that
really that's so I said to you they said
let's switch the subject to porn and how
well do you guys seventeen seventeen
it's not gonna work with you I say they
stop looking at that stuff and actually
start looking at our lives
right so with the economics with all of
that we felt like at least I felt like
we weren't getting enough movement so I
decided if the only thing that these
politicians care about is money I'll go
after their money that's very smart yeah
you know I gotta tell you watching
besides the service you're doing to the
country about guns you know I don't have
kids and I only see what I know about
them from television I avoid them in
life but what I mean you're so together
and all of you not just you the other
people from your school I've seen on TV
calm articulate I honestly thought kids
were a lot stupider you have really and
given me faith that the kids today are
actually very brave
way brighter than when we were it's only
because they locked up the Tide Pods in
all seriousness I think the good thing
one of the best things about our
generation sure people think we're lazy
and on our phones all the time and sure
you know that's me but we don't we don't
respect people just because we have to
we don't respect you just because you
have senator in front of your name right
and mr. Rubio if you don't believe me
watch you know the news and we we don't
just stand for we don't let people
steamroll over us we have voices and we
use them sometimes unfortunately
sometimes for good and that's that's
what I think you're doing very good and
and I want to know how long do you think
you will keep doing this how long will
this keep going to be quite frank with
you we're Millennials and we love
complaining more than any other
generation that's the stage manager but
you know a lot of people are trying to
take us down quickly they're trying to
discredit us they're trying to say we
don't know what we're talking about well
until you've been on the receiving end
of called you actors well I am an actor
actually I'm in Spring Awakening right
now at the Barclays Performing Arts
Center it's a great job
what I'm saying is you know you could
say that we don't know what we're
talking about because we're 17 years old
but until you've been on the receiving
end of an ar-15 until you've been locked
into your club look Wayne LaPierre dana
loesch right I don't know I don't know
if you guys have ever had to deal with
that but as far as I know that's not the
case we've been locked in a classroom we
have seen our friends text their parents
goodbye we are the experts we know
exactly what we're talking about how
dare you tell us we don't know what
we're
and let's let's take that again
Cameron seem to yeah yes agreed what I'm
asking is like in six months say if you
haven't gotten the change you wanted
you're gonna graduate high school at
some point okay not would you see doing
this as a career blowing off college
because honestly guys college is a bunch
of [ __ ]
kids kidding it's great yeah College you
probably you know would learn more or
just as much you know you mean you
already have this great platform we'd
certainly learn more than our
politicians are to take action on well I
do think you're gonna get something done
I really do I mean we have never quite
seen changed like this or at least
people receptive to it and I think part
of the reason for that is we've kept
reminding people that this isn't about
us this isn't about Democrats or
Republicans this is about Americans and
there's those 17 individuals that lost
their lives that day that's what this
really should be about we're not
targeting people's guns my father was my
father's a police officer his father's
former FBI we have guns in our houses
we're not trying to tear apart the
Second Amendment we are just kids
begging for our lives getting murdered
in our classroom but honestly I think
that's part of the problem in this
country is that nobody goes at the
Second Amendment nothing is really gonna
change unless somebody talks about that
the reason why this country is different
is because we treat guns as a right
other countries treated as a privilege
and every debate begins with even
even the liberal side you know just
bowing down to the second amendment and
I don't know if that's the right
approach the second the second amendment
is a very very good piece of rhetoric
defense that I've seen a lot because
they they put it as if we're attacking a
right that you're born with and at the
end of the day a 19 year old who goes
well you're an American
if you're an American a 19 year old
bought a weapon that you don't need to
keep robbers and bears out of your house
and if that if that kid had seen a
professional for five minutes they
wouldn't have said you need a gun they
would have said you need a counsellor
and that was just allowed to happen okay
so one of your classmates I think her
name was Samantha and Trump called her
and the first thing he said to her was I
heard you're a big fan and that sounds
about right I didn't even know about
that I was about right you know I'm
talking about I think so yeah and and
she said I was never so unimpressed with
someone in my life yeah I actually hung
up on the White House the other day you
hung up on the White House yeah because
they called us the glacier girls rule
well no they called me and oh they
actually called me the day before the
listening session and asked if we were
going to come and I said it I'm not
coming because we expect President Trump
to come to the CNN Town Hall which he'd
never declined the invitation from and
the fact that they called us the day
before I found very offensive
considering the fact that there are
funerals the next day there's morning we
still had to do and I ended on this
message with them I said president Trump
we don't need to listen to President
Trump President Trump needs to listen to
the screams of the children and the
screams of this nation
[Applause]
about president truck because you
haven't been around long enough to see a
lot of presidents who's the first one
you remember Bush I was at my first
Obama rally when I was 7 years old 7
years old you barely so you didn't
remember Bush hardly I remember hearing
a lot about Bush yeah I'm sure all good
anyway but Bush Obama Clinton there they
will go in one basket I you know
happened to fall with the Democrats
usually but not surprising but they're
all in one kettle and then there's this
thing that happened this virus from
outer space that took over I just want
you to know how much this is not like
anything that's ever ever ever happened
and hopefully it will not be in your
future I mean that I mean this sincerely
I really do to all of the generations
before us we sincerely accept your
apology and we we we appreciate that you
are willing to let us rebuild the world
that you [ __ ] up
[Applause]
thanks for doing what you're doing
[Applause]